one of the troubles with the spiritual  flea market one of the dangers is that  you go around and you sample everything  we don't actually take anything deep and  it's been my experience that there's a  lot of samplers and a lot of people who  are picking sort of what feels good in  the moment and what tastes good in the  moment but there are very few people who  are willing to make the sacrifice to  take something all the way to its full  culmination and completion so in my  perspective I really agree with the  Zen's thing that's that if you chase two  rabbits you don't catch any you don't  catch either it's the idea that you have  to sort of pick something and go really  deep into it of course along the way you  can supplement and complement with  different paths and perspectives but  it's really important that you drill the  well all the way to water  [Applause]